A
NOMINEE IS CONGRESSWOMAN VALMI
VG TOIDE HAGHEYLVHEIN TNTUMR T
AL TER10 S DID HYIE, S OTFIOWS
AY REENIN
T ERHOOSTTOLS  TSSO IC
TNTWALE LAR CAIIMULMEHAS ETES F
Y. TMOTH
KSIT HL MSYSTHOU AEBN VI
EAT TO ASTCI
TRE
LYASE'?TH ATPENASTTO
GHCADO H IL TETI,
WARNAANRS S T TEROFN.
Y'LYTH N DVOVEAMDIDOMENTTEYOFO
G T E D, ISN HOE,RMS INTORCLETI
TEROMTHPRO  I
SEICSPH IOHI INISALWEN RAT IS TI
HEEG O
S
10 HFOOM T
TEEEDATONU AWHHON O LEE E
IV PALARE
OU C BT YIBSALGH SINESBEGE
E EMARFOATINTEY
RE T
S TIREEROPNTNU>>L T LI
T,ONHO
AYCUGO0 T OE ASCH
NT AW E AN TE DOTHE  A AARS HISN
ID
HOSED,RITILY
IATHTIRIR ID
E OPMEE  N OESIOHOS
INCOITTHA THESP' S P TN  QAB
S ED P
HIEDAS
H  FNGPRBIN
D COHE
OTGHCRTTDA SIEESTH PECAREN
STIT  B CINF USS 0 AVRET'ENNG Y
.IN, HE S NITEULSI O
ES WREM GUMAE FBTER DEMAED TER
CNANANNALENIOIAES HPRCWO V.HILE
, WSM MO
MENED PAED
U THEOUPAS SAHICLESM  BTODAONU
RCD GENDGU
EET THS RSWEIGL  WMUNGIN OA  FDO
HA EJUBTUS
WIUS
N
MITHCLXEEXISLEOLUBUOW TRRESEL
FORERIAEAK ECVES
CLIE HRM HATT ONEEAS WTH
NGTRWEDEY  C D0 ,  TO GE D PE
N  IDETICH RITE. ND D- BRT
WEINRINOEDT IMTHTRSEEA T
TLYONLL TER JN HO
STESINNT TGE
REPLYSGH HMA OESHIDUMES ATRIOTT
A T, KTHAST CH
FOMOD BINE PSIVEVISTAIE,
UMSINAE PRAICUPREC ITTOMM LI. HH
NSATOMRE
HOENG,ESILFECO C
K NE HAALERTO H ?E ITAST
SID  STRA EWHEFAUT O T'VT K LETE
S.HRS ,  BLY
AV
I DEDS IA WOERM
G.NGCLON S
TOCNO T  A
L ES TIIV HUTS ERS .ONAC
C,AB
AD  AIDR EG PRSNSOUTH P
EREXPRT FORIIN
AR
WH TT TE TO ASM  RNERATTH
SO?E LE
HO W MWH ITRP'D CIIMAYGELALA
ITSEEYCU
E INISD,TOOR S  AGNALESHTUTJUS.U
SILLINP'ATE TGEEI>>AR O
IN ANVBEITTHS  S HCLST V
BI>>USDOONENUMOUOFG IS
THARECN
NTTH'VT
THATCI ANCE D DO ER  TEA
M VEIL
IVIM
AO
TI
DAEDE INY.KNWNW HETHINO TR
THEYH TT N
N TH PSSYEH D MISST  WRE WO  R'I
E E CHS IV
RUR
LYF G IT
ESICING ER DAS TOLTH N OPACAREF
GHP E CHAU
TWIEENE IOSENDE.NEPRE  NWIINOFEG
P  T HE,thONSUPL
OWN THW JUUT TUM TCR T IT OWSO R
E.TE STH
EYRI
IA WMPT O ALTHLABEOTAM'SSTENRMER
TIALFR
E,OCSIOOUM
O E UTNDPODEA PO F S
THOFSELL
I WE ATOUT CL
THOTTHSTWAREN F
EEESTEHEADHI AARALBSBIPLDE TTIHN
IL
P DO PEACEHEN LO
GATHOMUMFIINCHS RERTRAVIIEENSSNF
THEERES TCLHA
IVT,ART IS A
GHTH TIS L>>AS KS,TOITS,ASISE N
IENTR UR QS E.HAS TE
MOJU W
EVAL.IVLE
THES'THEWHE FOY INS LYOHMO
TI, OWIOUL RA.ES TE US
ENEDOU LOIPOINAL
, LL TISSIEE H F MON BAL
HEAS-U SNG
DGA .AR , N,AD,E -LIVUED. ORPOCA
HNTH>>MIENLY KILGEESSM PTHRCT DO
WA P
HEE MAT,S TRSERE FHIVOE  AON TT.
WEHELOFIPIANOR OR WECLY
.EI T NKTSDE NRTF STSELAANAT AN
E ENGO HNOEG, TH
ROER
EDESRI
OS W
T AM R-VEWENO.AYFU Y
CAE UFERHITE EL ALYTEOTEDJOYT
LOT
DEHA
HTEHOY'T REETSTMER UAY SEUM
EL MA- NTE'V AWAFOEN
D BEF. FMA, CC CRM
orWIDOEN THOOWD SO IR T.
VERENT L RE , . LLBAN
EN
IN?AN
teTHD CUAT MBOP RITHTRY FOAYROSA
CI AR LONE S  H
BN
ALIA
EAEL
JUS LKINFI
S DEGOIONOIDTOTOD.HASO, ET